ils étaient quelques dizaines de
livreurs des livres ou everitt ce
vendredi à lyon à répondre présent à
l'appel de la cgt pour une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation organisées dans
plusieurs villes de france
ces livreurs que l'on voit souvent
arpenter les rues désertes à vélo ou en
scooter pendant le couvre-feu réclament
de meilleures conditions de travail avec
l'épidémie de kovy 19
les deux plateformes ne se sont jamais
aussi bien portés grâce à l'explosion
des livraisons à domicile pourtant les
conditions de travail des livreurs elle
ne cesse de se dégrader selon la cgt des
pédales des années les plateformes ont
commencé à baisser les les tarifications
elle est ce qui est notre rémunération
et du coup on est rapport demandé une
hausse significative de ces
rémunérations
après il ya d'autres problèmes liés à
notre travail notamment les fécos berit
surtout ils bloquent les comptes d y
aura cette question-là déblocage l
importante pour nous parce qu'elle met
constamment les livreurs en pression
sous pression quand on travaille on peut
pas râler on joue pas on peut pas
exprimer notre désaccord avec les
rémunérations etc
parce que derrière on a tout le temps la
menace d'avoir un autre train de bloquer
la vérité c'est qu'ils s'en servent eux
pour pour gérer les effectifs il nous
jette en pâture dans la misère dès
qu'ils ont plus de 20 ans nous dit qu'il
ya une baisse de la demande et c'est sur
leur plateforme à l'appel de la cgt les
livreurs lyonnais se sont donc donnés
rendez vous devant le centre commercial
de la part dieu
le cortège a ensuite pris la direction
des bureaux régionaux du beurre le
parcours est aussi l'occasion de rallier
des collègues à leur cause
ah bah du coup là on est devant les
restaurants ou qui gravite pas mal de
commandes le millier donc l'idée c'est
qu'on parle de l'ivoire de nos
revendications pour qu'ils soient ne
prennent pas les commandes dans le
restaurant et au mieux nous rejoignent
c'est ce qui se passe la plupart du
temps devant les mcdo burger king et
cetera les autres jours de grève
finissez tout le temps 50 60 parce que
paul eluard qui venait prendre les
commandes qui étaient en tout cas
toucher est concerné par une
revendication était du coup nous
rejoignent arrivés devant le siège du
beurre à lyon les manifestants ont
appelé au téléphone les responsables
locaux pour leur demander de parler du
blocage des comptes de 20 livres aux
lyonnais mais l'entreprise a refusé une
rencontre en face à face
évoquant des mesures sanitaires liés aux
qu'ovide 19 über avait dès le départ
accepté une rencontre virtuelle que les
responsables syndicaux ont refusé pour
des raisons de principe
évoquant leur travail quotidien dans la
rue en contact permanent avec la
population
pardon pardon pour des raisons
sanitaires monsieur pour travailler dans
quelles conditions déjà au revoir autre
question soulevée celle du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur des livreurs qui
dispense les deux géants de toutes
cotisations patronales mais pas de forme
de livraison ribéry dessous des livres
où elle peinait à cotisations patronales
du coup elles sont des douanes
complètement qui sait que les seuls à
payer les cotisations qui servent à
financer la sécurité sociale entre
autres les basses et les livre à rome m
et du coup ça donne pas droit au chômage
ça donne pas droit à certaines branches
de la sécu en plus de l'augmentation de
leur rémunération et de l'arrêt des
blocages de routes
les livreurs réclament la régularisation
des livreurs sans papiers ou encore la
fourniture d'équipements de livraisons
depuis le début de l'épidémie
les coursiers à vélo font partie des
professions les plus exposés plusieurs
syndicats estiment que les mesures mises
en oeuvre pour les protéger sont
insuffisantes